Back in the days when there was just
one screen density for devices,
a designer might create a pixel perfect
logo or other graphic in Photoshop.
Now that was fine,
until more screen densities started
coming along, like HDPI and XHDPI.
You'd need to redraw the pixels
in the graphic at a larger size
to ensure it was the same
physical size but
look perfectly crisp on
the higher density screen.
With four or
five popular density buckets these days,
this practice can get really tedious,
really really quickly.
Designers who don't want to repeat
themselves should use a graphics app
that can work with and
export vector graphics.
Apps like Photoshop and
Gimp are geared primarily to
working with rastrographics.
That means they store the actual
color information for
each pixel in the resulting image.
Those raser images can be
scaled down with no problem but
you start to see blurring and other
bad artifacts when you enlarge them.
Vector graphics apps like Ink Scape,
Illustrator, and
Sketch, instead store information about
the individual shapes in the image.
For example, the center and
the radius of the circle.
So you can scale the image up or
down without any loss of quality.
The shapes will just be
drawn at a larger size.
While Photoshop let's you work with
vector graphics too, Illustrator and
Sketch actually let you export your
graphics to vector format like SVG or
Scalable Vector Graphic.
In newer versions of Android, you can
directly use vector images in your app,
using a format similar to basic SVG.
Sure beats exporting a bunch of png
files over and over again, right?